President Biden's border policy.
Katie Britt is Margie Taylor Green
with a blowout and a gel manicure.
They're the same person.
They fight for the same things.
It's just that Katie Britt
does it with a trad wife aesthetic,
which is this misguided nostalgia for,
you know, a past where white women had fewer rights
and women of color had no rights.
It's a movement that's built on traditional masculinity,
that women have to be subservient to their husband.
But it's like,
kind of empowerment
because women are choosing to,
uh, be subservient.
But the Tradwife, you know,
aesthetic is not in movement,
is not just rooted in sexism,
it's also rooted in white supremacy.
For example,
a Tradwife started the White Baby Challenge.
So the Tradwife is like white nationalism with lipstick.
And it's not surprising to see the Republican Party
really go after white women
by literally
putting their biggest female rising star in a kitchen.
Like, the Republican Party has spent decades
trying to court white female voters,
using white nationalism to get them to vote
against their own interest
for Republican policies and candidates.
And the Republican Party has been
really successful at this.
If you look at the last 18 presidential elections,
white women went for the Republican.
Even though people are saying that
the state of the union rebuttal,
um, didn't go as planned,
it went exactly as planned.
Just based on their policies.
This is the future that Republicans want.